[Music]
hello everyone we've got another
exclusive tip 2019 interview for you
right now this is for the movie
synchronic you guys might recognize
these two over here who came in for the
witching hour to talk about the endless
big fan of everything you do let's just
jump right into it really quick
synchronic for everybody out there who
does not know what this movie is about I
know it's tough to do this over and over
and over but can you give a quick
synopsis yeah it is about to paramedics
have been friends their entire lives
played by Anthony Mackie and Jamie
Dornan and they're in New Orleans and
they stumble across this series of very
grisly seemingly impossible or strange
First Responder situations and they're
all linked together by an
over-the-counter designer drug called
synchronic which has some very bizarre
effects and Ally actually do want to do
you want to tell you're part of it yeah
my character takes the drug and then she
goes missing oh and she is the daughter
Oh true yes Jamie Dornan one of the
paramedics you also get one of the
coolest sequences in the movie and I'm
not gonna spoil that but it is something
else where did this idea start from
because obviously the the high concept
is the time-travel drug but there's so
much else character-wise going on so is
there any starting point that got you
access to the entire thing you know
there's there's so many movies that
whenever they go back to the past
especially it's the 1950s or 1960s until
we romanticized and has this sort of
probably dishonest sheen on it where I
was like yeah it was probably great for
a few people but like a very small
subset of the population and the further
you go back in time even like if you're
watching like a like a have a
Renaissance period piece or something
it's like yeah good for some people but
but not again small subset of the
population so it was like it was that
idea looking other time trial moves
especially something like Back to the
Future where it's like that future is an
amazing fell miss beloved you can't if
it's in a room you have to watch it but
again you look at Marty McFly if Marty
Marty McFly weren't white heterosexual
male that story would be very
you would be much bigger dangerous than
like you know his mom trying to hook up
with him very very very true it does add
a really interesting layer to this movie
that we haven't really seen before in
time travel
films do you have a time travel Bible
somewhere and does that Bible stay
consistent from film to film because I
don't know I feel like you guys probably
have an obsession with time I've in some
respect there's definitely a cohesion
between the four films there's even one
line in synchronic that does tie it to
the world of the endless and resolution
that's okay
I mean are we doing a spoiler I guess we
are we're talking about 20 people okay
we're gonna here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna do a non spoiler interview
and then I'm gonna come back to that and
we'll do a separate little video that
everyone gets the opportunity to see the
movie will cover that okay I would say
that yeah I would say that the
time-travel thing is part of a spoiler
because it only comes in about an hour
into the movie but it's up to you
because it's hard to dodge okay okay
we're gonna push pause on that for now
but I'm coming back to it in that
separate video I keep something a little
bit about the casting process on this
one actually before we even get there I
feel like the last time we spoke about
the endless what was that last last year
end of the year yeah when did this movie
actually get the green light and when
did you start shooting it we got the
green light in June 2018 and it's
September 2019 so it was a pretty pretty
quick process pretty quick to turn
around we started shooting in November
2018 okay so probably right after you
came to visit us that's a that's quite
the turnaround and the accomplishment to
premiere at TIFF so soon after was the
assumption that I made earlier correct
that you guys had more resources to work
with on this one than you ever have
before yeah there was a little bit more
not not as much as you might think given
the level of the casts and everything
but but but it was definitely more than
we had had in the past for sure and what
was it like getting this film off the
ground compared to your last ones did
having the endless in your back pocket
make more of a difference than ever the
endless specifically is what made it
happen just because an agent happened to
see the last screening of The Endless in
a theater because they liked the poster
and that agent is Jamie Dornan is agent
and so they they hit us up and that got
the movie rolling and that at that
agency because they're both wrapped at
UTA and we were able to get our
Dreamcast to say oh wow so given that
experience when you I know we're looking
ahead a little too far right now but
given how this one came to be and how
you got a green light does that change
the way you're gonna approach your next
feature because there anyway you can
kind of you know try to recruit someone
like that that person who's kind of like
the the linchpin of getting the green
light yeah I mean we've been trying to
approach celebrity talent that would
greenlight a movie since our first movie
resolution and it's a resolution spring
and the endless to get to that point
where someone out there was like I
really am really gonna push for you guys
this time so we've been trying forever
and hopefully what this means is is that
doors a little more open than it was
previously I don't understand that it's
like maybe after resolution you know the
first time around you want a second one
to really prove yourselves but like that
paired with spring it should have just
made all of them come a lot faster and
can you tell me a little bit about
getting Anthony Mackie into the equation
because the chemistry between Jamie
Dornan and Anthony Mackie is key you
don't want to pass on someone like that
if that opportunity comes to you but you
want to make sure they've got that right
vibe going yeah well honestly it was
just we we watched
I mean who hasn't seen Anthony Mackie
movies but we watched The Hurt Locker
and Detroit
big lot of stuff because that's a that's
as much darker work which this is and
and that was that was why we wanted him
I mean of course and he's a he's a
world-class talent and luckily that door
was slightly open because Jamie was into
the script and Jamie and Anthony had
talked about working together before and
so that this was their opportunity to do
it so Ali I want you to make the two of
them blush right now also because the
last we spoke it was just me Haley and
the two of you so I'm curious from the
performance perspective what is it like
working with the two of them as actor
directors can you tell me a little bit
about them being co-director for you
yeah yeah it's it's amazing like they're
so trusting of everyone that works for
them which i think is really beautiful
and really brave and they're also just
really nice people and they're really
funny like a lot of people were like how
was it like filming that I've seen those
really intense but I think they were
joking around like I feel like it was
really fun
and yeah like even though it was he was
fast and like we didn't have a lot of
time like it was I felt really safe like
to be able to express myself and like be
in the moment yeah there's like really
funny like cool people they're really
fun to hang out with too so I could get
that sense talking about just the time
travel and that extra layer that you add
to this it makes me think of something
that I often think about when it comes
to anybody at Lake people always ask
where would you want to go if you can
time travel and I always say not back
because there's a lot of problems and a
lot of luxuries you don't have access to
and the fact that someone verbalized
that in this movie kind of validated my
standpoint on that but for all three of
you if you could hop in a time machine
and go back what would you choose and
why I I think for me it would only just
be about going to go hear really good
music live oh that would be the only
thing I wouldn't want to go see how the
world was or anything like that I
wouldn't want to go get healthcare from
1917 I wouldn't really want to go back
before I couldn't like pull the
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy out of
my paw
and just find out any piece of
information I want
so yeah just be the fun little culture
things and then immediately get back
here yeah the last time I answered this
question it was specifically to go back
in time to be present for a certain
movie premiere really which one which
one I want I was there when Jurassic
Park opens but I want to revisit that
feeling as an adult so many years later
but I also want to be there for when the
first Star Wars movie opened up that
feels just such an incredible game to
get a taste in the air at that period
when it first hit theaters would just
wowed everyone with this innovative
thing for the first time to get a taste
of that would be a dream come true have
every two maybe I'd like to see the
dinosaurs I feel like if I had the
chance to time travel like like I would
I'm not afraid of the rest like going
back would be really cool like I'm down
like I even like after seeing synchronic
like I'd take it I can't go back to a
period of time that didn't have you know
proper toothbrush toothpaste and contact
solution for seven minutes
I just realized as long as you can get
back yes as long as I could breathe the
atmosphere and it's seven minutes and I
know that I'm gonna go see a dinosaur I
would love I I'm sorry about your
Jurassic Park I don't mean to co-opt it
but I would love to see it for you
that's a really cool idea the more
Jurassic Park love I can spread in my
life the better yeah what you got uh I
wouldn't do it I just wouldn't do it
oh I can't like a really shallow answer
like
Oh like I it would be interesting to
experience independent cinema in the 90s
as an adult and be like oh there used to
be like all of these clearly like cool
chatty movies and they were police send
all these theaters and that might be
kind of fun but it's also a really
shallow answer and I am that's a fair
point
back in the day in the 90s because I
grew up in the 90s and I'm seeing all of
the you know just like the big things
hitting the multiplex is that I saw with
my friends and family what was the first
independent movie you saw at a very
small son in a very small theatre that
kind of you know maybe change the way
you looked at cinema as a young person
where I grew up in Florida didn't have
any independent cinemas so my first
independent cinema was actually in
college and the one that I remember most
strongly and unfortunately it's not like
a cool little movie it's there'll be
blood
I remember seeing there will be blood in
cinemas yeah but it was only like 15
years ago we're not talking about like
you know the golden era of indie cinema
we're talking about like what Oscars
that we still remember when I was in
high school I saw SLC punk at the
Hillcrest cinemas in San Diego that was
really key experience it was getting
interesting then I saw space I see 2001
and re-release at the Ken cinema which
is the same cup which are both landmark
now but both small San Diego independent
the University that's that's another
thing that I think we need more of
re-releases like that I just I'm sorry I
have to revise my answer because I
realized it was dishonest there was one
called the Tampa theatre and I saw a
double feature of Ryan Johnson's brick
and Casablanca for the first time ever
that was awesome that was transformative
I feel so much better that there wasn't
any cinemas over there but that was a
great great answer one thing that I do
actually remember from our last chat
that I want to bring back up is you in
particular a very positive outlook on
the rise of streaming services because I
stress daily at this point that
we are going to lose the big screen
experience as we get more streaming
services out there so I'm just curious
from November of last year to now
especially with Disney Plus on the
horizon has that changed your stance on
that at all and especially while you're
trying to get distribution for a movie
like this no it hasn't really changed my
stance the the positive outlook had had
some nuance which is as an independent
filmmaker it's just really hard to get a
movie made and streamers are starting to
just throw money at independent
filmmakers to make the weirdest stuff
and we didn't there was that there
filling a gap that didn't exist before
now also you know the big caveat is we
don't know what Disney's gonna do which
it could be wonderful and it could be
that all we ever get to watch is one
kind of movie and because they have you
know they're a steamroller
we'll find out but the fact is is
Netflix hasn't really slowed down on
green lighting weird stuff that you know
and the theatrical experience you are
correct is becoming something a closer
to vinyl but also we've we've heard that
that there's actually been kind of a
resurgence and weirdly enough in some
ways thanks to the box office returns
from Disney movies which is an odd way
to feel right so the other thing that's
a that that we were talking about then
was movie pass was a big part of it
because but now it's subscription
services to very large movie chains
nobody's fault like that's what movie
pass gave us was a response you know a
market response to all-you-can-eat
cinema and for me that's just wonderful
because if if you if people are worried
about spending $17 on a ticket to go see
an independent film and they just be
like I don't know I just need to see a
really big film for that kind of money I
understand that mindset I don't feel it
but I get it if there's a subscription
service that solves that problem but if
it's only at the really big chains that
only play really big movies we got a
problem back so it's just a
give-and-take that keeps on going back
and forth and once by month I feel like
every single time a piece of news breaks
that stresses me out about the future of
cinema I need to just like ask your
opinion could you have a very positive
sunny outlook on it and makes me feel a
lot better
well the other thing too is is that with
all of these streaming options they have
to create content for all of these and
TV that's been creating this content is
better than it's ever been
you know like show the leftovers seasons
two and three with some of the best
cinema of my life just isn't on a big
screen that's all you guys think about
moving over to the series format at all
I came from secular I actually feel like
this scenario could suit that because I
do wonder like does synchronic exist
beyond this continuing story that we got
we we agree with you TV executives we
agree
one one one thing we've talked up a
synchronic that'd be really interesting
is exploring the manufacturers of
designer synthetic drugs there's such a
bizarre weird crazy business because
it's like you're recklessly making these
molecules that are just barely legal
rushing them out into the marketplace
and like have it getting your buddy to
graphic design the package it looks
ridiculous you're testing them on
yourself and your friends or not at all
think that's the option there's no
medical research on them I know there's
going out to like a handful of gas
stations and and headshots are sold
online that is in like that the thought
process of being like we have to make
packaging that stands out on a shelf
with bath salts k1 and spice you know
some some DJ with frosted tips that like
knows Photoshop is like get in and make
your synchronic package the part about
Anthony Mackey's condition come into the
story too did they did that end
synchronic and what it is go hand in
hand or did you need a way for
synchronic to make sense to work for him
a lot of the time people feel like the
doors of perception are are is via the
pineal gland it's it's unproven it's
just kind of in mysticism but it's
interesting everybody kind of knows it
it's located where the third eye is and
all of that and so we thought okay if
this is a film that is affecting
perception I'm sorry if this is a drug
that is affecting perception and also
deals with these cosmic issues of death
let's let's use that as a mechanism so
him having cancer honest pineal glands
that seems to affect his method of
perception
was wasn't I mean it took a while to get
there but it was a natural progression
once you realize it because also we have
a paramedic who deals with death on the
rig and now has to look at his own
premature death in the same way and when
you came up with the story was it always
set in Louisiana because when you talk
about all that kind of stuff I mean
third eye it just seems like it fits the
like the New Orleans vibe very well so
is it always the plan to set the story
there yeah yeah it was it was always New
Orleans you know there's so many
cultural layers in New Orleans there's a
lot of really interesting spirituality
in New Orleans so even though there's
literally no connection between you know
synchronic and New Orleans voodoo for
example there's something interesting
about that vibe I'm just putting it in
that world
absolutely I'm gonna say congratulations
and I'm gonna say goodbye to everybody
who hasn't seen synchronic but if you
want to hear more about this movie we're
gonna have a brief spoiler video coming
your way when the movie is released
thank you guys so much for watching this
do not leave this video without liking
and sharing it and we'll be back soon
with more tips coverage